the latest research on school start
times and school performance shows that
if you change the school start time from
one that begins really early for example
seven o'clock to one which is much more
in tune with the child circadian rhythm
grades go up and the children do better
and and this is something that I think
people need to be aware of there have
been actual states where they have
changed the school start time for the
whole state this is happening for
example in Minnesota in some states
people are sort of chipping away at this
issue school system by school system but
in general it's much much better if the
child is able to start school at a time
when they are wide awake and alert
otherwise there daydreaming they're
asleep they're not performing as well as
they can I had a visit with a school
superintendent of one of the school
systems in Connecticut because I had a
patient that specifically had a problem
of not being able to handle waking up
five thirty in the morning in order to
finally start of their school classes at
7am and it was and you know and I was
met with sort of like why is this a
problem of the child waking up so early
in it and it hasn't quite entered
everybody sort of thinking yet that that
the children need to sleep the right
amount and they need to get up at a much
more reasonable time I can tell you that
I moved here from from Canada where the
school start time was almost nine
o'clock in the morning and and we didn't
have this problem of dragging children
out of bed in order to start school and
I'd love to see that here in Connecticut
parents need to recognize that their
child's performance is going to is going
to impart depend on how much sleep that
child gets and how alert they are and so
sleep needs to be made a priority and in
other words if a child needs 10 hours of
sleep at a given age they need to get 10
hours of sleep and the parent is going
to have to be hard-nosed about it if the
bus schedules is inflexible and can't be
changed so they're going to have to be
hard-nosed about it and just lay
lay down the rules and because otherwise
what will happen is the child will not
achieve the grades they can achieve and
that'll have a huge effect on them for
the rest of their life and a lot of
people don't realize that that that
doing poorly in school or failing even
one year is something that's going to
follow them for a big part of their life
you